>>> FRESH EXAMPLES OF HOW THE
TRUMP EFFECT DEFINES REPUBLICAN
POLITICS IN THE IMMEDIATE FOCUS
ON THE NEXT ELECTION AND THE
EARLY MANEUVERING FOR 2024.
DAVID PERDUE IS OUR NEW EXHIBIT
A IN THE HERE AND NOW.
PERDUE IS MAKING LOYALTY TO
TRUMP AND HIS BIG LIE CENTRAL IN
HIS NEW PRIMARY CHALLENGE
AGAINST GEORGIA'S REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP.
GOVERNOR KEMP REFUSED TO HELP
TRUMP CHEAT.
PERDUE SAID HE WOULD NOT HAVE
CERTIFIED THE GEORGIA RESULTS.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID, NOT WITH
THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
AVAILABLE AT THE TIME AND NOT
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT HAS
COME OUT NOW.
NOW FACTS CLEARLY DO NOT MATTER
TO FORMER SENATOR PERDUE, BUT
REMEMBER THIS TOO, A RECOUNT
CONFIRMED JOE BIDEN WON GEORGIA,
AND SEVERAL TRUMP LEGAL
CHALLENGES FAILED.
LET'S DISCUSS THEM.
AS WE DO, CNN'S GABBY ORR JOINS
THE CONVERSATION.
IT'S PROOF POSITIVE DAVID PERDUE
WANTS A MAINSTREAM REPUBLICAN
BUSINESSMAN NOW A BIG LIE.
>> HE'S NOW A FULL ON TRUMP
SUPPORTER.
IT'S NOT JUST GEORGIA.
WE'RE SEEING THIS IN OTHER
STATES, NORTH CAROLINA, OHIO,
WHERE THERE ARE THESE REPUBLICAN
SENATE PRIMARIES WHERE, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE CANDIDATES WHO
TRUMP AS HAS ENDORSED AND SEEING
SOMEONE LIKE PAT IN NORTH
CAROLINA, WHO TRUMP THINKS
BECAUSE HE'S LOST IN THE PAST
HE'S NOT GOING TO ENDORSE HIM,
AND WE'RE SEEING THIS REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY PLAY OUT THERE.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, NEXT YEAR, WE
MIGHT HAVE SOME INDICATIONS OF,
YOU KNOW, HOW REPUBLICANS CAN
POSITION THEMSELVES IF THERE IS
ANY LANE AT ALL FOR SOMEONE WHO
PERHAPS SUPPORTS TRUMP POLICIES
BUT DOESN'T QUITE SUPPORT THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF OR THE BIG
LIE.
SO THAT, YOU KNOW, WE'LL SEE HOW
THOSE PRIMARIES PLAY OUT,
INCLUDING THIS ONE.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HOLDING A INTERNATIONAL
FORUM ON PROTECTING DEMOCRACIES,
AND YOU HAVE CANDIDATES WHO ARE
RUNNING, ACTIVELY IGNORING
DEMOCRACY.
>> AND PERDUE, IT'S KIND OF
FORGOTTEN.
IN THE SUMMER OF 2020, THERE WAS
THIS COMPLICATED TWO SENATE
RACES HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME, AND DIFFERENT METHODS, BUT
HIS RACE WAS JUST A STRAIGHT
HEAD TO HEAD, AND HE WAS -- HE
NEEDED TO GET 50% OF THE VOTE,
AND HE WAS ACTUALLY RUNNING BACK
THEN AS A KIND OF MAINSTREAM
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICAN WHO
WANTED TO WIN THE SUBURBS
OUTSIDE OF ATLANTA, AND WAS
SAYING NICE BIPARTISAN THINGS
ABOUT ISSUES, CONTENTIOUS ISSUES
LIKE POLICE REFORM, AND HE WAS
GETTING RECRUITED TO GO BACK
INTO THE SENATE RACE, AND HE
LOST AND KELLY LOEFFLER LOST,
AND RAPHAEL WARNOCK IS RUNNING
AGAIN.
PEOPLE WANTED HIM TO RUN IN THE
SENATE RACE, HE SAID NO, BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T WANT TO GET CAUGHT UP
IN THE TRUMP STUFF.
>> AND HE GOT NUDGED AND PUSHED
INTO THIS.
LET'S TAKE A LEAP FORWARD TO
2024, MOST REPUBLICANS THINK
DONALD TRUMP WILL RUN.
AND HE HAD A CONVERSATION, WHAT
IF YOU DON'T.
>> IF DONALD TRUMP DECIDES NOT
TO RUN IN 2024, WHO OUT THERE
WILL THAT BASE FLOCK TO?
>> IF I DO DECIDE THAT, I THINK
MY BASE IS GOING TO BE VERY
ANGRY.
I'LL DISCUSS THAT SUBJECT RIGHT
AFTER THE MIDTERMS.
I KNOW EXACTLY, I MEAN, I HAVE
TWO OR THREE THAT I THINK WOULD
BE VERY GOOD, BUT I'LL MAKE MY
DECISION.
>> GABBY, YOU HAVE A GREAT PIECE
ON CNN POLITICS.COM ABOUT HOW
THIS AFFECTS EVERYBODY THINKING
ABOUT RUNNING IN 2024, NIKKI
HALEY, FORMER U.N. AMBASSADOR
SAYS I WOULD NOT RUN.
KRISTI NOEM, I'M COUNTING ON HIM
RUNNING.
RICK SCOT SAYS HE OUGHT TO RUN.
THERE'S A HOST OF OTHER
POTENTIAL CANDIDATES WHO GIVE
DIFFERENT ANSWERS, SOME LIKE LIZ
CHENEY, RUNNING AGAINST TRUMP
WHETHER TRUMP'S IN OR NOT.
IF YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT 2024,
YOU HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO THINK
OF TRUMP.
>> THERE'S NO WAY AROUND IT, AND
AS YOU MENTIONED, THERE ARE A
FEW REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE COME
OUT AND EXPLICITLY SAID THEY
WOULD NOT CHALLENGE HIM IN A
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY.
THERE ARE OTHERS IN A DIFFERENT
TIER WHERE THEY HAVE SAID, YOU
KNOW, WE'RE COUNTING ON HIM
RUNNING, AS KRISTI NOEM HAS,
MARCO RUBIO SAYING THAT HE WAS
OF COURSE BE THE NOMINEE IF HE
DID RUN.
OTHERS INDICATING SUPPORT BUT
NOT QUITE GOING THAT FAR, AND
YOU HAVE THIS GROUP LIKE LIZ
CHENEY.
AND TRUMP ALIGNED CANDIDATES,
MIKE POMPEO, WHO AREN'T WEIGHED
IN AS 2024 BUT TALKED ABOUT AS
POSSIBLE CANDIDATES AND HAVEN'T
SAID THEY WOULDN'T CHALLENGE HIM
IN A PRIMARY.
THAT IS NOTABLE FOR PEOPLE LIKE
MIKE POMPEO, MIKE PENCE, TWO
PEOPLE WHO SERVED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHO HAVEN'T
EXPLICITLY SAID THEY WOULDN'T
CHALLENGE HIM IN A PRIMARY.
>> YOU MENTIONED PENCE.
CNN'S RANDI KAYE GOT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK.
>> Reporter: IF DONALD TRUMP
RUNS FOR PRESIDENT, WILL YOU
STILL RUN?
>> YOU KNOW, OUR FOCUS IS ON
2022.
I CAN HONESTLY TELL YOU IN 2023,
MY FAMILY AND I WILL DO WHAT WE
HAVE ALWAYS DONE.
WE'LL REFLECT, WE'LL PRAY, AND
DETERMINE WHERE WE MIGHT BEST
SERVE AND WE'LL GO WHERE WE'RE
CALLED.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE A PRAYER
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP IN 2024
SHOULD HE RUN BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE A LANE.
HE THINKS IT'S WHITE
EVANGELICALS, BUT I THINK DONALD
TRUMP IS PROBABLY MORE POPULAR
AMONG WHITE EVANGELICALS THAN
MIKE PENCE IS.
HE'LL TOYING WITH IT, MAYBE I'LL
RUN AND PRAY AND LOOK FOR THE
LORD'S GUIDANCE, BUT I THINK HE
DOESN'T HAVE MUCH OF A LANE
OUTSIDE OF THESE WHITE
EVANGELICALS, AND THE BASE
DOESN'T LIKE HIM.
TRUMP HAS TURNED THE B